model that not only produ single value
predictions but also um a quantification
of uncertainty quantifying how confident
we are in these predictions and we'll
see how this works um during this talk
but before that um a little bit on who I
am my name is Quan I'm a PhD student at
Washington University in St Louis and my
research revolves around basian machine
learning and decision making under
uncertainty and in my research I use a
lot of gazan processes ACH P so it's a
topic new dear to my heart so I'm pretty
excited to be talking about this with
you all today um you can find me on
these uh social media links especially
my GitHub repo where you can find um the
slides that we'll be looking at today as
well okay so with that out of the way i'
like to start by start with this um
simple motivating learning example so
let's imagine that we are trying to fit
a simple one-dimensional regression
model on this
um data set of three trending data
points uh visualized as these black axes
here um so these data points right they
are observation from some unknown Target
function that we're trying to learn um
the blue solid line that I'm showing is
a prediction the predictions made by
this Kor R regression model we don't
have to know what that model is but it's
just a common ml model that people
usually use in the real
world um so I said that the prediction
the predictions um generated by this
model is single value because at each
point each test point that we're
interested in we only have one single
number to represent our prediction so
for example at x equals ne1 here our
prediction is around
ne25 around xals 3 our predictions
around 25 five um and this is not just a
particular characteristic of kind of R
progression right it's most typical ml
models work this way where it just
produces single value numbers as
predictions and that's something that I
particularly don't like about these
models and I'm hoping in this talk I'll
convince you of the same thing um
specifically this this this uh drawback
that there's no Arrow bars no
quantification of how confident or how
uncertain we are about the predictions
we are generating and if you are
building a model in a setting where you
want to use these predictions to inform
this your decisions that you may make in
the real world that might have serious
implications then um this lack of
uncertainty quantification could lead to
a lot of serious problems specifically
lack from lack of trust from the
user so um and I like just just like to
say again right um this is not a a
problem with just Conor regression but
other models like a decision tree or a
neuronet also has this
problem this and I'd like to kind of
talk a little bit about um this lack of
uncertainty quantification a bit more so
um while we are making predictions with
a machine learning model right there's
this regime where we call interpolation
what we're trying to interpolate between
two training data points that are close
by for example this region we we are
saying that we're inter interpolating
because we are just imagining how the
unknown Target function that we're
trying to learn from behaves between two
training data
points but we also have extrapolation
right where we are trying to make
predictions about the target function
when we're further away from the
training data where we don't have a lot
of information and in terms of
uncertainty or in terms of confidence um
uncertainty should behave differently
when we are interpolating versus when we
are extrapolating right when we are
interpolating we are close to our
training data so for example this point
and this point then our uncertainty when
we are making these prediction should be
low but when we're extrapolating when we
are far away farther away from the
training data then our uncertainty
should be high again with this um Conor
ra question model we don't have this
kind of Distinction of uncertainty when
we are extrapolating versus
interpolating and this is where the
gazan process or the GP comes in right
it works and we'll see this we'll see
why this is later in the talk it works
by accounting for how similar each test
point that we want to predict on is to
the training data points that we have
access to so the predictions generated
by a GP has two components the first is
this solid blue line again which just
shows um our mean prediction
that is the most likely values that the
labels that we trying to predict take
but we also have this shaded region that
shows uh 95% confidence intervals of or
Arrow bars which quantify uh uncertainty
about our prediction and these Arrow
bars achieve exactly what we wanted
right where if we are interpolating over
here we have uh pretty high confidence
or low uncertainty right qu by a very
narrow Arrow bar but when we further
away from our training data we are
extrapolating then this Arrow bar
increases gradually to quantify our
increasing uncertainty so that's very
nice to have and um this you know
principle quantification of uncertainty
leads to increasing use of the GP in
recent years especially in decision
making under uncertainty applications
like we said where um we have to
carefully reason about what our models
know and don't know so in this talk I'm
hoping to talk about the underlying
mathematical intuition behind the GP and
we'll see how this principle
pontification of uncertainty is realized
with a
GP and the punch line and this is I
guess spoilers but the punch line is
basically that a GP is just a
generalization of a multivar gan
distribution to very high dimension
and by using a multiv g and distribution
to model um correlations between
different random variables we achieve
this quantification of uncertainty that
we really like in a GP so in this talk
we'll see how this is actually
achieved and um I've had a chance to
talk about GPS with um couple different
types of audience and it seems to me
that to talk about the GP is the easiest
by um easiest with um this particular
example that we'll look at um on this
slide so let's imagine a toy scenario
right where um you've been living in St
Louis Missouri uh which is where I go to
school but you just got a new job and
you're looking to move away to a new
city so you want to sell the house that
you're currently living in but a problem
that you're facing right now is that you
don't you're not actually experienced
with the housing market so you don't
actually know how much you should set
the price of your house at um so imagine
that you're talking to your friend right
and you said oh I don't have a pretty
good guess so anything between 100K and
300K is probably okay um but I would
like to narrow down this range because
it's very um big so it's not very
informative and what you like to have is
a reference point uh price of someone
someone else's house that
they recently sold so your friend comes
along right and they said oh uh this
person that you know Alex sold her house
for
250k you actually misheard your friend
though you thought that um your friend
meant Alex who's living in California so
a completely different person living in
California um so you said that oh that's
um that's a pretty low price for a house
in California but that doesn't really
help you narrow down the original price
range which is between
100 and 300 again this is natural right
because knowing the price of a house in
California doesn't really help you with
selling the selling a house that you
have in St Louis Missouri uh but your
friend actually corrects you saying that
oh it's actually Alex your neighbor
instead and upon realizing this m
mistake you said oh that's really
helpful information because not only the
two houses are close by but they are
also very similar so that helps you a
lot in narrowing down the an appropriate
price for your house which is now just
190 between 190 and
270 so um what exactly happened in this
conversation right and what does it
actually have anything to do with GPS
and um alternative
quantification um we could realize the
connection by kind of framing this
conversation using the language of
machine learning so in the beginning
right what we have is an inference task
where we want to predict the price of
our house which is so predicting the
label of the test point the price of our
house now your friend comes along and to
offer a potential training data point
which is a which we interpreted as just
the price of a house in San Francisco
and we said that this is not pretty
helpful because this trading data point
is pretty far away from the test point
it's very different it comes from
completely different distribution so
that's not going to be very helpful in
predicting the predicting the label of
the test point that we're interested in
but upon realizing a mistake right we
see that oh this trending data points
actually the price of a neighbor's house
which is um a very similar data point to
the test point that we're interested in
so that would be very helpful indeed in
helping us with the infant Tas with
predicting the price of our own house
and um as we'll see in this talk even
though the CHP Works um in the more
slightly comp at way the basis of the GP
Bas comes down to this um procedure of
comparing whether a test point is
similar to some training data point or
not and by using that measure of
similarity we can generate these uh
predictions that come with uncertainty
quantification or Arrow bars that we
really interested
in and we do that again by using multi G
distributions
um and we we and some of you might be
familiar with um the base case for the
multi gion distribution which is just a
Univar gason distribution or
onedimensional normal distribution the
probability density function or the PDF
of this
distribution um you might be very
familiar with it it's just the regular
bell curve that we are showing on the
right and each distribution right is
parameterized by two um two numbers the
first is the mean um which is just at
the center of the bell curve and then
the variance Sigma Square which defines
the spread of the bell curve so if we
have a random variable X that follows
this normal distribution then mu the
mean value would be the value that X
most likely takes and sigma will
quantify our uncertainty
about whether X will actually take on
some value that's close to Mu or
not this uncertainty is also Quantified
by this object which is called the
confidence interval a 95% confidence
interval is exactly equal to Mu plus and
minus uh 1.96 Sigma um which is this
region that I'm showing on the right
here um we're calling it a 95%
confidence interval because it this
range consists of
95% of the probability mass of this
distribution or 955 % of the area under
the curve and sometimes we also use this
notation which is this bold Arrow bar
here to um indicate this confidence
interval okay so this is the base case
right the univariate gas and
distribution case but we can also
generalize this um distribution to
higher Dimensions by accounting for
multiple variables at the same time and
that's what we get when we use a multi
Gan distribution
using a multi distribution we model not
only the individual the distributions of
individual random variables but also the
correlations between those
variables and we still have two
mathematical objects to um describe the
mean and the covariance of this multi-
Rion distribution um here because we're
working with multiple random variables
we have a mean Vector mu um and a cence
matrix Sigma the mean Vector here is
again describes
the it basically concatenates the
different values that the different
random variables most likely take and
most of the time we just normalize this
mean Vector to the zero Vector with
without having to worry about it but the
co Matrix actually more um interesting
it um again quantifies the spread of the
individual different random variables
but also the correlations between them
and more specifically right the diagonal
entries of this cence Matrix um describe
the variance of the variables so for
example Sigma 1 one will be the variance
of X1 Sigma 22 will be the variance of
X2 and so on um the off diagonal entries
describe the co-variance of the
corresponding pair of random variables
and we'll see an example of this right
now so let's imagine right that we're
working in a two a 2d case where we have
two random variables so what we have is
a by Vari gon distribution um and what
we can do is we can plot out the
probability density function of the PDF
again now as a heat map in 2D so the
docker colors here are showing higher
probab density values right higher
probabilities so looking at this right
we first notice that the spread of X1 um
horizont Al is smaller than the spread
of X2 vertically and this makes sense
right because uh the variance of X1
which is one is smaller than the
variance of X2 which is three but more
interestingly we see that this Pat map
is sled to the right which shows that
there's a positive correlation between
X1 and X2 so if X1 takes on some high
value then X2 is also likely to take on
some high value and this is explained by
this co-variance between X1 and X2 which
is 09 which is quite
big but if we don't have a positive
correlation between the two variables
right if the co is exactly at zero then
what we have is this symmetric uh PDF
where um regardless of which value X1
takes um are the distribution of X2
doesn't really change because again
there's no correlation between X1 and
X2 um I really like this um heat map PDF
visual ization because it not only tells
us right the indiv the distributions of
the individual variables but also the
correlations between them but when we
move to higher Dimensions when we have
more than two random variables then we
cannot really easily plot out the PDF
anymore it's not really easy to plot a
function in 3D or in higher Dimensions
so what we can do instead is to use this
um alternative visualization which I
which people usually call the parallel
coordinates plot and what we do is we
plot out the 95% confidence intervals of
individual random variables in parallel
um so here we have X1 here we have X2
and here we have X3 um note though that
we are not really visualizing the
correlations between the different
random variables but that's the best
that we can view with um with this kind
of
plot okay
so this slide right has been about using
multiv regation distributions to model
um individual random variables and um
the correlations between them but that's
only one half of the story actually um
another part of the story that we're
interested in is how this how a multi
region distribution will change in light
of new data and if you're familiar with
the language of B and probability this
is the same as deriving the posterior
distribution of a
multivan so the task that we're
interested interested in here can be um
phrased using this thought experiment
right let's imagine that we have a multi
distribution modeling The Joint
distribution of D random variables
here now we get to observe the values of
some of them and what we're interested
in is how would those values change the
distributions of the other variables
that is what are the posterior
distributions of the remaining
variables and thanks to the nice
mathematical properties of a gan
distribution is amazingly still a mic
Gan distribution so posterior
distribution of Gan is another Gan um
with an updated mean and covariance and
we won't be going into the math of what
this updated mean and covariance are but
we can take a look at some examples to
see how this update procedure actually
works so let's imagine again right this
B VAR G distribution here where the two
variables are highly correlated to each
other quantify by this 0.9 coant
value again we can use this parallel
coordinates plot to show the individual
distributions again and let's imagine
that here we get to observe that the
value of X2 is exactly three and we are
interested in seeing what the posterior
distributions of these two random
variables are and here I'll just show
the result in Orange right so in Orange
here they are they are the 95%
confidence intervals of the posterior
distributions of these random variables
so taking a look at X2 we see that this
posterior confidence
intervals it's very narrow right the
upper bar and the lower bar is
basically concentrated around three
which actually makes sense right because
we our knowledge says that X2 is exactly
equal to three so there shouldn't be any
uncertainty regarding what X2 is so the
confidence interval basically shrank to
just one single number three over here
but on the left we also and this is
pretty interesting I think we saw that
the posterior distribution of X1 changed
pretty significantly so first of all it
shifted up and then the confidence
intervals um also shrank a little bit it
shifted up um because right there's a
positive correlation between X1 and X2
and X1 here sorry X2 here is taking a
positive value three so X1 is also more
likely to take on a positive value so
this distribution shifted up but because
there's a correlation between the two
random variables and we are gaining some
information about X2 then we should also
uh gain some information about X1 so our
uncertainty actually decreased a little
bit in terms of what the value of X1 is
which is pretty
interesting and we observe the same
behavior where we where we have a
different observation for example let's
imagine here that instead X2 is revealed
to be um equal to
-2 then um the confidence interval of X1
now shifted down to reflect the fact
that x one is now more likely to take on
negative values but the width of the
arrow bars again also so decrease a
little bit to reflect our
um reflect the fact that our knowledge
about X1 increases with information
about
X2 okay so in the final case where um
here there's no correlation between X1
and X2 where this off diagonal entry is
exactly Z zero then what we see is
pretty interesting right regardless of
what value X2 takes the posterior
distribution of X1 actually matches
exactly with the prior so it doesn't
change at all and this makes sense too
right because um because there's no
correlation between X1 and X2 so um
whatever value X2 takes that shouldn't
affect um the value of X1 at all so the
posterior distribution stays the
same okay so at this point you might
already see where we going where we're
trying to relate this back to the
original uh example with the housing
price um and the connection here is this
right we can model the unknown housing
house prices as random variables using a
multi ging distribution with appropriate
coari ciance values and then we will use
this update procedure to see when the
value of one random variable is revealed
how would that affect the distributions
of the other random variables or how
would that affect a knowledge about the
other prices the other house prices so
if we concatenate the price of our our
own house in Missouri the price of um a
neighbor's house in Missouri and the
price of the third per the third
person's house in California into a
threedimensional vector then we can use
this triari gason distribution to model
um The Joint distribution of these three
random
variables and we can use the same
parallel coordinates plot to show the
individual distribu utions and more than
that right and this is where the fun
comes in I think um where we can follow
the conversation that we just that we
had in the beginning to um to see how uh
how these individual distributions
actually change in light of new data so
if you remember in the beginning we
misheard our friend right we thought
that our friend meant that um the person
in California she sold her house for
250k um um which was pretty surprising
but it doesn't narrow down the range for
X1 that is upon realizing upon observing
the value of x3 um the third variable it
doesn't change the distribution of the
first variable um this makes sense right
because there is no correlation between
X1 and X3 as Quantified by um this value
this off diagonal value value in The
cence
Matrix
now upon realizing that we misheard a
friend right we realized that the
training data or the observation
actually meant that um X2 the second
variable is exactly equal to 250 instead
of x3 so by conditioning or by updating
our distributions using this correct
information we are able to obtain um
this posterior distribution for X1 here
which is a lot more narrow and that is
why are able to narrow down the range
between which was originally between 100
and 300 and now it's just between 190
and 270 which is a lot smaller and
that's exactly how um we were able to
achieve that intuitive update procedure
using the language of mathematics using
this uh multiv Gas
Distribution okay so that's the 3D case
but as you can imagine right a
multi-region distribution can model um
The Joint distribution of any number of
random variables um so we don't actually
have to stop at three let's imagine here
that um now you are an analyst and um
studying the prices of 20 houses on a
plock and you have this very particular
Co correlation structure that you want
to model which is that nearby houses
should have similar prices and Far Away
houses should have uncorrelated prices
which is is pretty reasonable then you
can use a 20 Vari gon distribution to
model um these uh 20 random variables
using for example this cence Matrix here
where the um entries close to the
diagonal have higher values and the
entries far away from the diagonal have
lower values and that exactly reflects
the correlation um structure that we
wanted in the beginning and what we do
right is again use this parallel
coordinates plot to plot out the the
individual variables but
also um use the update procedure to see
how these um individual distributions
will change in light of new data so here
I'm showing um the result when we
observe that X10 the price of the 10th
house is some positive value and we see
this very interesting Behavior right
where the price of the distributions
nearby this 10th variable are updated so
that the mean takes on a higher value
and the standard deviation of the
variance decreases but when we move
further away enough then um the
posterior distributions are exactly the
same as the prior because there's not
enough correlation between the training
data and the test
data okay so this is where the punch
light comes in um we've done it we've
done the update procedure for three
random variables we've done the update
procedure for 20 random variables and
now what we want to do when we want to
do regression is we want to make a
prediction at any um input location any
random variable that we like so by
effect right in in effect we are
extending this multiv G and distribution
to infinitely many random variables
infinitely many unknown quantities and
that's exactly what we get an infinite
variate Gan distribution and that is a
gausian process or GP where instead of a
mean vector and a CO Matrix we have a
mean function and a CO function mean
function you can just basically set it
to zero most of the time Co function you
some people use this radio basis
function or RBF Co that has this very
particular form and what this form does
for you is that it will increase when X1
and X2 are close to each other and it
will decrease when X1 and X2 are very
different and that's exactly what you
want in terms of the correlation
structure so when we come back back to
the original regression problem with
these three training data points what we
can do right is we can ask ourselves
what are the test points that we're
interested in let's imagine in the
beginning we're interested in these
three test points then we can use a
trate ging distribution to model the um
these test points the labels of these
test points and then use the update
procedure to obtain the posterior
distributions of these test points based
on the training data but again we don't
have to stop a three r variables let's
say I'm interested in all integers
between five and five then this is the
the updated distributions that I'll have
and I can keep increasing the size of
this test set to have more increasing
granularity when I make the prediction
and in the limit right when I have this
test set to be a very dense crb with
infinitely many test points then what
I'll have in the end is this um gaussian
process or GP
and that's exactly what we what a GP is
it's basically a multiv g and
distribution extended to infinitely men
many random variables okay so I'm I'm I
see that I'm running out of time so let
me quickly wrap this
up um in Python when you want to
implement GPS you can use this state of
the r GP um Library called G python that
allows you to implement GPS in a modu
way so you want to implement your mean
function and cence function um and by
swapping out different mean and cence
functions you can induce very different
behaviors that you want and I'll speed
through this slide here because I'm
running out time and I just like to
conclude this talk by
uming this this test which is called
basian optimization and it's an
optimization framework for blackbox
expensive to evaluate objective
functions using GPS I actually give a
talk at P data last year on Bas and
optimization so be sure to check it out
if you're interested in how GPS are used
to solve real world problems um but I
also recently wrote a book on this and
in the book I talk about how the GP can
be used to kind of balance between
exploitation exploration to optimize for
an unknown function and there are other
topics in the book that I think are
pretty interesting um this is apply from
modeling housing prices in California
this is a plot where we combine a
neuronet with a GP and since you're a
pator you can actually use this discount
code to get I think a 45% discount on uh
this book on any other man books um I'm
very out of time so thanks so much for
listening and I'll be happy to take any
questions offline on Discord